russia's Foreign Ministry calls the
country's banned from the upcoming
Winter Olympics painful the
International Olympic Committee
announced yesterday that Russia will not
be allowed to compete in Korea over
widespread state-sponsored doping the
games opened February 9th
mark Phillips is in London with the
latest mark good morning good morning
well to the IOC its punishment for
state-sponsored cheating to the Russians
it's unjust humiliating collective
punishment to the Russians the IOC ban
is part of an international campaign to
belittle the country the ban means
Russia as a country will not be
represented at this winter's Games its
Olympic Committee has been barred and
certain officials suspended for life
individual athletes with no doping
history can apply to compete but as
Olympic athletes from Russia
no anthems will be played at ceremonies
if they win the Russians have long
dominated many winter sports but they
apparently weren't taking any chances
at the last Games in Sochi the IOC says
a state-sponsored scheme swapped out any
positive samples and swapped in clean
ones to ensure no positive test for
Russian competitors and the man who ran
the scheme says the order came right
from the top Grigory Rodchenko 'the big
boss lady but Putin saying we have shown
the best result in Sochi Vladimir Putin
did not take an opportunity this morning
in Moscow to comment on the ban but the
Kremlin continues to deny there was a
state-sponsored scheme saying individual
sports officials and athletes should
take the rap a number of Russian
athletes have already applied to compete
under the new rules
the IOC says they'll be subject to
stringent doping tests but the medal
count for Russia at the coming games
will be zero Noora zero indeed mark
thank you so much